justin lin valverde itunes tyson et saïd
ben oui qui est notre invité ce soir
alors comment ça s'est passé le casting
je suis quand même bon et c'est la haine
après vous avez fait un certain nombre
de films dans le monde en italie en
espagne au maroc et commence comment ça
s'est passé comment vous avez été
contacté pour tourner à hollywood enfin
en amérique et bien tout simplement par
le biais des agences pas ce qui se passe
c'est comme vous l'avez dit lines a fait
le tour du monde
donc ça a permis à beaucoup de metteurs
en scène de remarquer un peu le travail
qu'on n'y fournissait etc
et du coup voilà quoi les spike jones
qui met bien mon travail et j'ai qui est
un ami personnel de david o'russell et
voilà ça s'est fait comme ça tout
simplement j'y suis allé et puis on l'a
on s'est rencontrés on a commencé à
travailler et lounis ça s'est passé
comment avec lui c'est vrai que le
premier jour du tournage il vous a un
peu provoqué pour jouer au basket avec
vous pour vous tester c'est ça bien que
ce qui se passe c'est que oui il y avait
il ya toujours l'attention quand les
acteurs se rencontrent parce que vous
soyez de l'admiration ou surya de la
peur ou de la crainte enfin ya plein de
choses qui se passe et ce qui se passe
c'est que c'est vrai que quand je suis
arrivé là-bas mais c'est des gens très
simples et très très très très bien quoi
c'est à dire qu'ils sont très
professionnels aussi mais george hill a
un côté un peu plus sympa c'est à dire
qu'il est très humain donc il aime bien
le sport surtout donc effectivement une
that is à dire hey joe basket et ça
s'est passé comme ça la rencontre quoi
avant même de commencer à travailler
donc c'est pas ils vous nous met à
l'aise quoi ça donne envie de travailler
il ya pas mal d'acteurs français qui
commence à s'exporter en amérique on
avait virginie ledoyen ici dans la
dernière émission guillaume canet bien
sûr avec elle dans dans la plage croyais
pas que si on veut faire une carrière
américaine il faut s'installer là bas
parce que finalement catherine deneuve
elle n'a jamais voulu y aller et l'a
jamais fait de carrière américaine et
antonio banderas tuiles a eu le courage
de fall courage courage enfin il a eu la
volonté de quitter l'espagne il a tourné
le dos à sa carrière espagnole est
finalement maintenant il est devenu une
énorme star à hollywood après pâques il
faut habiter là-bas c'est pas moi je
cherche pas à faire une carrière
américaine moi je considère comme
citoyen je vais le dire du monde
l'homme était un petit peu déçue vous
après la haine tous les films qu on vous
proposait c'était des films vous étiez
dit leur épicier et ça s'est passé s'est
passé pas très très grave ça s'est il
faut attendre que c'est normal c'est
l'histoire des cases c'est à dire que
quand tu marques un peu l'esprit des
gens mais vous dites c'est très bien ce
but vous dit j'ai envie d'être acteurs
pas arabe c'est vrai que les américains
il juge plus sur le talent et les
résultats que sur le que sur le physique
ou sur la couleur de la peau c'est vrai
qu'après la haine on vous a proposé des
trucs qui était un peu réducteur par
rapport à vos ambitions
ben voilà peut-être que c'est ça en fait
c'est dire que tu travailles beaucoup
pour arriver à une certaine maturité de
travail donc à partir de là tu as tu as
peut-être pas envie de la partager avec
n'importe qui ça peut paraître un peu
près 30 prétentieux comme ça mais c'est
pas du tout prétentieux c'est parce que
c'est parce que c'est pas facile c'est
vrai quand il n'ya pas de beaucoup de
stars arabes en france il va pas
beaucoup le mot de sa moye exemple je
dirais ouais je sais pas effectivement
quand on se penche un peu sur l'histoire
du cinéma français n'y a pas beaucoup de
stars arabes alors je sais pas si c'est
une volonté précise qu'il n'y aurait pas
ou alors arabe ou de couleur tout
simplement ya pas que les arabes il ya
aussi nos amis disparaît aussi toute la
communauté asiatique enfin y'a plein de
choix je crois que la france
multiculturelle plurielle et cetera elle
n'existe pas vraiment elle est là et en
même temps je crois que les talents ils
sont obligés un peu de sexe c'est pas
facile de partir travailler à l'étranger
ça vient il faut quitter sa famille
c'est à dire qu'il faut quitter les gens
qu'on aime sa maison ses habitudes sais
pas c'est pas super super évident donc
en fait tu le fais parce que c'est la
seule façon d'exister aussi pour toi
qu'on sait qu'il faudrait des quotas
comme le disait ici quelques beyala
concernant la télévision c'est à dire
vraiment on obligera les gens
mais la télévision engager des noirs des
asiatiques etc
je suis pas méchant que ça serait super
triste en france au pays des droits de
l'homme d'installer des quotas pour
qu'il y ait un nombre d'arabes et un
nombre de noirs dans les films
maintenant s'il faut en arriver là où
dans les publicités
maintenant s'il faudra en arriver là bas
je trouve je trouve que c'est la seule
et unique solution il faut le faire
ouais vraiment parce que c'est pas
possible de continuer comme ça en même
temps c'est triste c'est super tri se
trouve en france qu'elle est vrai que le
phare du monde mais pourtant vous sentez
très français vous dit si nous étions en
guerre contre le maroc
je me battrai pour la france ouais je
sais votre grand-père à votre grand père
a fait la guerre d'indochine n'est pas
ça c'est dire que je suis je suis né en
france j'ai grandi à partir de là je
sais pas quoi quand je travaille
justement avec les américains ou alors
avec les italiens ou les espagnols ils
me disent mais tellement français si on
peut les partager dans tous les cas tout
ça c'est un peu complexe josé vous
trouvez pas que c'est quand même les
médias lé cinéma en france la télévision
ne traduisent pas vraiment la réalité
technique du pays d'ans habanos vrai que
c'est clair qu'on voit pas beaucoup de
films d'abord avec des réalisateurs
venant d'autres origines si on en croit
pas beaucoup non plus et puis vivant
retraçant la réalité ou même de la
fiction à partir de la réalité qu'on
peut voir dans les rangs du sujet il un
problème d'acteurs et puis souvent quand
ça se fait ça se fait de manière
caricaturale
on le voit pour les banlieues comme on
le voit pour les campagnes c'est la même
façon c'est toujours une caricature
c'est toujours quelque chose qui n'est
pas du courriel seront pas la vie des
gens et c'est vrai que c'est frustrant
mais même j'allais dire au niveau
purement nationaliste la patrie tu me
diras tu es français pourquoi et
étrangers pour certaines choses et pas
pour d'autres
ouais c'est dommage non moi je suis
d'accord bien on va faire une interview
première fois lumière faire ch